C event that I had that I wanted to talk
to I was listening on to a podcast on
the way here and they were talking about
the uh the SAG strike the writer strike
and one of the problems was um the use
of AI so oh my god did you guys see that
[__] video that I sent you about how
gnarly deep fakes are going to be so
gnarly but to to get to that point so
that they they referenced at the end of
the movie Flash they they had an AI uh
CGI character that like used to be an
old flash or whatever and the people uh
maybe that guy like the trust saw that
and they're like well wait a minute he's
on the movie like is he is his likeness
getting paid for that and so I figured
the question is like okay so if they're
going to start using Ai and the actor
doesn't even have to be there for the
movie how much is it a licensing thing
well I I saw something that said that
uh like background
actors are getting
paid like for one day of work to film
like a thing that makes their likeness
like in perpetuity throughout the
Universe
forever like uh oh [__] so they're going
to be always in background I guess like
an extra if you're cuz people do like
kind of make a living or at least a
part-time living doing extra work but
now it's like you'll work one time and
like now we got you and we can use you
forever and they don't have to pay them
well but they must be signing something
right they they said that uh this one
tweet or something that I saw said that
um like Bill Gates got paid every single
time somebody downloaded a Windows but
like a background actor gets paid one
day work for their stuff to be used as
like much many times forever ever I mean
but the paychecks got to be pretty big
because no one in their right one day of
work no it's 160 bucks I mean it's not
big
now right mind is going to sign a
contract for 160 you read the [__] 78
pages when you like sign something or
you're just like yeah [__] it okay okay
yeah and then you got to get a lawyer
for that my question to you is like one
of 10 years down the road they used they
did film the jackass and they used AI to
do your character they're doing stunts
would how much would you want to get
paid from that it's like wait a minute I
mean that's but that's the argument is
here saying that AI is doing the stunt
so there's just no Stakes there's
nothing yeah the jackass example doesn't
really work but if it was like Leo
DiCaprio in a movie but he doesn't have
to show up they just use an AI version
of Leo how much does he get paid like
that uh Black Mirror episode exactly
like that Jo Joan is awful yeah with uh
Selma Hayek yeah yeah I mean so like
that's the question is like okay they're
signing things like well you did sign
this in perpetuity they can use your
likeness that's a licensing it is it 5%
temp like what do you do yeah I think
extras should be getting paid for that
obviously you shouldn't just work one
day for like 60 bucks and then they own
you forever and they can use you you
know and have you get killed by an alien
and Spider-Man or whatever and I don't
know what else there the strike is
really about I know that the writers are
uh upset that the streamers are not
paying them um like residuals for for
streaming well it's not only they don't
pay you for streaming cuz some people
they do like directors do get residuals
from Netflix but Netflix just says this
is what we owe you you can't audit
Netflix like there used to be uh
companies like the neelon ratings where
they're a third- party company that is
keeping an eye on things and sending you
what is owed to you but this is Netflix
just saying you we owe you a thousand
bucks but you can't audit to see the
numbers of like how did you come to that
number how many views am I getting what
am I getting per view like they don't
you don't have that access to info in
like network television people are
getting residual checks for like 13
cents and they're like well like Network
television is dead it's all about the
streaming services they're residual
these CEOs are they said for the year on
these some of these CEOs like but Bob
Iger made 27 million another guy the
last five years I mean the top five made
about 3 to 400 million each for the CEO
position and they're like well people
aren't getting paid can you can you look
up how many people are on strike right
now because they said now now the actors
are on strike the actors the actors and
the writers are both on strike and they
said they haven't done this since 1960
and I think there's 171,000 people on
strike that's you know how long is that
going to go for so the big picture a
strike by Hollywood's largest Union
which encompasses 160,000 members in
total that's actors what about screen WR
the the writers are on strike too so
that's actors joining the writers on
strike so now they can't shoot any TV
shows any movies they need content so
what are these big streaming platforms
going to do when they can't well they're
going to shoot more like they're going
to just get more shows from Korea and
stuff like that like you're going to see
squid games like eight showing up you
know they're not yeah Koreans aren't on
sag and yeah like it's just the US I
think that's striking so and I I read
something that uh Universal trimmed the
trees uh so the protesters didn't have
any shade while they were protesting wow
yeah so like now there's like a whole
investigation I mean I think the
streamers know what they get
investigates they're trees yeah I know
there's this whole thing about it it's
pretty wild yeah it's [__] Warfare
dude yeah I think that that's fair to me
I think the streamers know this can't
last forever like they will have to pay
residuals they will have to like be
auditable and show their numbers to
people and they're just holding on for
as long as they can cuz they're making
so much money and at the moment they
don't owe anybody's [__] well and they
said a lot of people these people
171,000 people or 160,000 people are out
of work so they said you know what do
they wait till their their third
mortgage payment is up and then go back
the negotiating table see if they're
willing to cuz these people can't do
anything else because they're in part of
a union so like we we've had the
conversation some people can't even come
on the podcast because they're in the
SAG and they can't talk about it so like
somebody uh suggested to me that I
should go to the the strike line or the
picket line whatever and and uh do
something or other you're a sag member
yeah yeah um and and my response to this
person was that I really don't
understand
quite what it's all about and I can't
help but feel that the entertainment
industry the conventional you know
mainstream industry just kind of lost
interest in me and now like I identify
as a
digital YouTuber in influencer guy a
non-union I kind of identify more as a
digital guy then yeah and you kind of
make your own work like you're not
waiting by the phone for somebody to
give you a job but still like what
happened with jackass and Paramount plus
was kind of probably [__] and should
be maybe illegal and like all this like
everyone working together to demand
change so that [__] like that doesn't
happen anymore but dude it's like not
it's not only that so you have all those
people on strike but what about the
camera crew what about the lighting crew
like now they're all out of work so it's
a it's a
bigger issue you know all these people
are out of work and so what because
they're in the union they can't like
start driving Uber or something I think
you can drive U U but you can't do what
your your trades in I wonder if Uber
prices will go down when jackass was put
to streaming were they telling you the
numbers on what it was getting or plus
um Paramount plus didn't exist when we
did our deals for the jackass
movie um and so it wasn't built into our
contracts that they could put it on
Paramount
plus as this is how I understand it and
um and then when the movie came out they
they did not take it to Netflix or to
get um an idea of its market
value they just sold it to
themselves and and they gave themselves
a pretty good
deal yeah yeah so we got kind of kind of
screwed out of that wasn't that what
they're striking for like now like I
guess I don't know yeah yeah I think
like actors it used to be like if you're
in an episode of The Cosby Show every
time that episode airs you're getting
paid it makes sense I I'm I'm glad
they're striking I hope they them for
striking I just don't feel really you
know personally emotional about
it but what about being I mean you were
pretty mainstream for years right so you
you don't think you have some sort of
like compassion for yeah I mean sure
compassion but I just don't ever feel
like I and maybe this is why I should be
supportive of the strike because I I
don't feel like I was ever particularly
looked out for by the right you didn't
get residuals from the jackass TV
show and you got [__] on jackass
forever plus I mean maybe I should be
like more and more you get residuals off
wild boys no God that's so [__] crazy
dude yeah that is crazy yeah I don't get
uh I don't get anything do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your buttthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and steo butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude